with the help this motion capture suit
we're actually going to try to transform
ourselves as a transformer when I was a
kid I loved transformers I dreamed of
transforming my body into a vehicle so I
could roll away from all my problems
just like optimus half the kids and
playground were over there you know
climbing the going down swing the other
half we're digging a hole I was in the
corner trying to contort my body in
different positions to like maybe maybe
just turn into a semi-truck it's
obviously impossible even now I can't I
can't do it I can dream though and with
the with the help of this Exxon's motion
capture suit I think it's possible we
[Applause]
[Music]
have the opportunity of borrowing a
mocap suit and then we get to have it
for two to three weeks slow and just do
whatever we want with it always gets
naked in the office you find the excuse
[Music]
I can get my thumb in here I get my tiny
little thumb all right we're good
getting into my suit
so there's 17 sensors on your body that
track gravitational pull magnetic north
and rotation so there's no cameras your
two bodies this moving sensors when we
send all that over a Wi-Fi channel into
the software and real-time you can
record and export the data or you can
live stream it into unreal community
MotionBuilder and Maya in real time this
is so cool
12200 gonna show up to an award show and
like that everyone be taking pictures
feel like I'm gearing up getting ready
for battle this guy comes in with a
twenty two thousand dollar suit and the
first things I can't wait to like glitch
it out and the guy's face is like look
if that man don't think Dobby don't live
in his suit then he died for sure look
at that that's the Dobby right there so
we got this motion capture suit
we all agreed the best use of this
motion capture suit is to turn ourselves
into transformers and we're actually
going to try to transform ourselves as a
transformer Sam found a really nice
model og Optimus Prime which was my
favorite rare yes yes we're halfway
there
look here theory you take this suit you
record yourself transforming like
Optimus does in the show you parent this
model to the data we capture through the
suit thus turning yourself into a
transformer where do my hands go no way
you can turn yourself into a truck first
off you need to have your knees like the
truth like this is so so stupid
you have to like twist your legs like
this come down like this and this should
work Sarah and myself were joking that
it would be really funny to name our son
truck but I imagine my son to be a truck
and I never came out a human man I mean
you have a transformer and okay no you
can form yourself if you just believe
Sam I believe you can turn into a truck
yourself Carmichael to read if you
believe in yourself you can transform
into that no the problem is that the
suit is like too accurate what you're
talking about is using the suit to
transform your own body and the suits
gonna replicate that to perfectly what's
this this is negativity the accuracy of
the suit is gonna work to our advantage
if I go like this it's gonna work with
the suit your arms have to literally
fold up like this I can do it I can do
it you just gotta believe that's fine
why am I so used to this I'm gonna try
and get this suit to communicate with
the computer capture that data and send
it out to cinema 4d so that right
can take the data and apply it to your
boy Optimus right here my goal is to
render myself driving away because I
could actually work so now I just need
to figure out how to capture new data on
my own
relax walk forward in a normal fashion
okay so that's me like 30 minutes
a lot faster than I thought it would
take this program is great the suit is
fantastic as you can see it works really
well the process for actually taking it
from raw motion-capture data to actually
applying it to a 3d model of like say
Optimus Prime looks like it'll actually
pretty straightforward
that's the optimism before guys it's
time to turn myself in topping this
Prime manually keyframe each of those
pieces
we're not manually animating anything I
will make it work it's the only way to
make it work you know because I'm a
perfect truck you're assuming I'm
showing your perfect truck race show me
a perfect truck well let me study the
model hold on hey check this out I
started learning how to do hair
simulations in cinema 4d I'm like super
early stages of learning how to do it
but here's the thing I want to be able
to take this to the next level always
wanted to simulate hair off of motion
capture data and I think I'm ready for
human trials now so the idea is I want
to have like one of us with just this
huge silky wizard beard ants around and
have a beard hanging off of my knee did
so I do need Nick to shave it's
completely coincidental to the sponsor
of today's video which is Dollar Shave
Club so today's video is sponsored by
Dollar Shave Club apply the butter
generously onto the shapeable area
smells so good so the cool thing about
Dollar Shave Club feed supplies you with
everything you need help you look feel
and smell your best it looks like I
broke into the Cinnabon Factory in what
the town
wait let me just try so as you guys know
finding the best products can be hard
and pretty expensive Dollar Shave Club
makes it really easy
they have top-shelf products that do
amazing things and they deliver
everything to you on your schedule
they got shower products oral care
products hair products skin products
butt wipes and obviously shaving
products if you have a body they have
you covered I can just get these two
little silver patches I did need more
butter though you're getting butter
under Bouboulina
budderball keep the butter get butter
down near butter boys you can get
everything you need for a clean face and
a great shave with their new $5 starter
set you're gonna get this executive
razor handle a whole pack of razor
blades tube of shave butter by dr.
Carver's wear effortless and delightful
shipping that's cool Wow so there's
hydrating citrus Hawaiian ginger daily
face plant I can use that but anyway
that's a lot of stuff all in this one a
little starter kit right here
[Music]
you like my catfish tracking markers
that's probably the only patches of
silver oh that's so gross oh my god
please keep that for like 24 hours I'll
keep it until my girlfriend dumps me
it's like chances are I'm only gonna be
really dangling the hair off of like
punished like generically your jowls
sweet I got some job there we just
finished recording the data we decided
to get this data in there and start
stimulating some hair but in the
meantime go to dollarshaveclub.com slash
corridor crew to get your special offer
all right now to put a brand new beard
on you all right check back later in the
video for this
[Music]
you've gone too far
this is so this is so just beyond we're
gonna round up the boys and we're gonna
capture some motion okay so your move
needs to happen they make sure
everything's calibrated make sure
everything's good to go and then from
there we hit record I'll go first
you know I'm gonna transform into a
truck real quick I'm gonna need you guys
to install my battery hey hey my hair's
perfect we have to actually study which
parts are which so I have to take a look
and study the model and make sure like I
know what goes where okay my wheels are
I just know where my wheels my wheels
are here so it's gonna be like
Transformers roll out okay you're gonna
give your hero pose and then you're
gonna start transformation okay I'm
ready to see what you got Clint I'm
ready to be unimpressed
oh yeah that'll totally where you're
about to find that okay transform my
expectations transform my heart three
two one clip that was the pose I was
gonna do that was pretty something okay
you're good to go
are you ready to transport are you ready
ready are you ready to transform are you
ready to transform you don't look like a
truck last one right you ready three two
one
transform that's not gonna drive I've
been studying the anatomy of Optimus
Prime here and I've come to the
conclusion that think I can get an edge
on this competition okay guys so I just
just got into the office a render has
been completed it's a 12-hour render of
a fully textured Optimus Prime put on to
my body man you know like one of the
most exciting things is coming to work
knowing you have a suite render waiting
for you and that that's what's happened
this morning we got the Optimus Prime
all linked up to the motion capture data
I spent all day yesterday texturing and
making you look super nice heading all
like scratches and smudges and the dirt
I'm really tired of chicken
[Music]
that looks so good autobots roll we
could make a short with asleep
yeah like janky transformers geriatric
Transformers Prime you dude could you
imagine just like Casper like
live-action geriatric Transformers they
turn into Oldsmobiles suits are so cool
oh my god
I need more I need more well link you
guys up milling your ears up
I'm gonna like yours ah I need more
can't wait to see your breakdance to do
great damn speaking of renders I hear
you got some beardy renders I do
so the first render I did I had a lot of
like frizziness curl waviness clumpiness
and all this stuff in it I'm just not
really looking very good so I resented
it and rendered out as a different one
doesn't totally line up with you as a
person whether it's the filtering that
takes some of it out it's like her
extreme motions weren't quite as extreme
in the CG model but nonetheless was
still able to drive the physics of you
like waving back and forth that even
interacted with your hand which is
pretty sweet
imagine Legolas growing out of your face
in what ends up looking like is fresh
spaghetti
literally spaghetti d do you need I
literally just glued a bunch of
spaghetti to your face and you just like
lip in her arms and there's a pretty
solid for your first hair test got all
this stuff ready to go I'm gonna wrangle
the office and show them the magic that
we have created is this V footage to
determine who's the best Optimus Prime
who can roll like the best Optimus Prime
who can actually drive like the best
Optimus Prime but yeah I will show you
guys this footage worked so hard I
worked so hard to show you when I'm
gonna show you right now Carmichael like
I've worked so hard to show you when I'm
watching you right now in Carmichael and
if you get just for a second if you
could just for a second please
oh that's pretty close I don't think I
[Music]
now we're gonna test the practicality of
all three of these poses who can
actually drive it look the best directly
I think that's a good point because it's
like transformers they walk around but
they also have to be functional all
right yeah here's first driving sequence
you know what though you know what at
least he's got all six tires on the
ground he's looking down the road thank
you yes
the problem is that yeah he's grinding
down his hands that chairs aren't on the
ground tough this is last-chancer here
we go
[Music]
alright this is the most nursing the
total to crack a little their
transformation I gotta go I gotta go
with Nick it's it's the most practical
transformation how do we know that's
Nick cuz it's obviously I can tell what
the body of work and out of the body
boobs have individual ways we move our
bodies and a motion capture suit
captures that that is pretty regrettably
is pretty cool that like a fact that we
can identify know yeah yeah who's who
based on how they move is pretty like
it's goes to show how well we know each
other yeah but for driving Reds
absolutely right I didn't even plan to
have to be the most practical I'm too
and too
I agree with Jake I know Jake at least I
got the transform though clean sure you
got the transform never going to be a
truck if I have to go back and work on
my transformation then I will do that
most clean twigs most runner-up I'm
sorry I didn't mean to steal your
thunder dude look like at the end of the
day I had fun right I just wanted to be
a truck alright and I got to be a truck
I got to be a truck you're the best
truck I'll take that I'll take that I'll
take that
I would ship wholesale products and you
across the country see that's a risk I'm
not willing to take I want my food is
gonna go spoiled I'd write a country
music song about you do not be paying so
many late fees and all the shipping
costs I hope we can mess around with
more motion capture systems maybe if X
ends wants to extend us another suit
extend the loan period extends wait our
knowledge about motion capture I feel we
learned how to use motion capture in
like literally two days that's pretty
good fully going from like I don't even
know what program to use to we have a
finished product it'd be really nice to
have a motion capture suit for the
studio so because this unlocks a whole
different kind of style of short films
that we can do with this or VFX we can
do with this stuff and like the fact
that there's no cameras connected to
that suit either it's just like the
Wi-Fi connection well like this is a
little
an idea I've been wanting to do for two
years now I've had that I've told you
guys about my noodle man idea right
noodle man
all right Syrian handle is right here
corridor digital finest you'll find all
these renders there they're pretty sweet
also subscribed please hit that Bell
gotta hit that Bell do both
why choose hit that Bell for the
notifications do it all a cornucopia of
actions that will let you be informed
about our channel